from a combat perspective I always and I
still feel like the meat and potatoes of
any amount of war game is combat
[Music]
my name is Roberto Clemente and all my
friends call me Bert I'm a senior combat
animator here at Sony Santa Monica my
name is Kim Nguyen and I'm a gameplay
animator hi I'm Sabra and I'm a senior
VFX artist on God of War Ragnarok
my name is Grace Penn and I'm a gameplay
animator in God of War Ragnarok
hi I'm Stephen I have a gba combat
designer on God of War and I create
interesting and memorable creatures that
players like to attack and defend
against
you make the move you gave them
personalities you gave them weight
VFX artist is to put the Power behind a
move you are in control of fire and
earth and water and wind whether you are
throwing your ax or on the receiving end
of an enemy spell the effects is what
really gives the movement and the danger
to every move that a character enemy
makes
I work really closely with the design
team and the tech art team on this
project specifically we actually work a
lot with camera along with the guidance
of our great camera team so I find
myself doing fight choreography
sometimes
Parts about being a combat designer
isn't the technical implementation of
creating a creature but it's really
navigating that line between frustrating
and engaging we want to make something
that makes players lean forward and
focus and really try hard against that
enemy and feel good about overcoming
that but we don't want to make them feel
defeated if they can't figure something
out and then it feels rewarding when you
win not because it was impossible but
because it was fun and engaging
foreign
we've heard the community cry out for
more mini bosses bigger creatures and
enemy variety and this time it really
leaned into that so I got to wear
Ragnarok who's going to be traveling to
all nine Realms and each Rome is going
to have like its own theme of enemies
that are very unique to that space for
example an alphon we're familiar with
the dark Oaks but this time around we're
gonna be fighting light up such as the
lighthouse Warrior
one of the key learnings from the last
God of War game is we won't have to
think about the camera and how close
combat is going to feel we already have
that knowledge so we can build upon the
close camera that we have and we can
iterate on enemies creating more
interesting scenarios
in the last game atreus was just
starting to fight alongside Kratos and
he was learning from the master
tactician so in this game he's trying to
prove himself a little bit more and we
built upon those mechanics with him the
previous God of War a trades was still a
kid right so he has a lot of dependency
on his father and for this game you will
see a Trails moving more independently
on his own as a companion
[Music]
in regards to VFX for Kratos I think
that the players really love is the
powerfulness of it when you are playing
as Kratos you really do feel like the
god of war and moving into Ragnarok we
want to really make something bigger
make it stronger make it more of a
spectacle you want them to be like oh my
gosh I didn't know that the blades of
chaos could get even better but look at
that
so as Kratos gets more powerful he's
going to have access to newer Combos and
newer abilities that will increase the
combat depth of each weapon for the
blaze one of the moves that I've really
enjoyed from previous God of Wars is the
combat grapple and we're going to be
bringing that with a new twist
I'm very excited for players to try the
blade gravel traversal moves that brings
so much more speed into the movements
and the dynamic feel to it
one of the ways we've expanded Kratos
combat this time around is we've given
more utility and choice to the shield
loadout
if you are a Perry person you could
really go for a shield that gears
towards carrying if you're a big blocker
then you could choose a shield that will
really match your play style
one new mechanical element that I'm
really excited about is these combo
finishers building up the stump meter
this time around is going to lead to
different ways to basically decapitate
the enemy you're going to be able to
choose you know which weapon you want to
have when you kill a guy
another feature that we've added for
Kratos is his new pre-fall attacks you
could jump off a ledge and if there's an
enemy below you you could slam down on
it
foreign
there is such an emphasis on verticality
in some of these fights that it's super
engaging and as Kratos now that you have
so much mobility and that you can also
take advantage of that verticality I
think it just adds such another
interesting layer to a fight
and God of War Ragnarok we've enhanced
the Kratos and atreus Duo he's going to
initiate a little bit more and be
aggressive he's going to fight alongside
you and sometimes even surprise you with
his combo abilities too some of the new
expanded companion actions that you'll
see at treya's Doom leverage the fact
that he's older now he's bigger now and
he's different from Kratos so his magic
has a different flavor
not only that the fight side by side
together there are also a lot of mini
games and you know player interaction
moments for example like the puzzle
systems and the set pieces we definitely
will see a lot more collaborations
between Father and Son
[Applause]
all right
Odin must have said that
there's so much that goes into building
a big set piece you basically iterate
and iterate and iterate and it takes
testing and just seeing what works to
really figure out the personality of
something basically every Department
gives it their all to make things really
spectacular
there were a lot of different times that
I would look back at God of War games
just Through the Ages before 2018 there
were so many amazing huge boss fights
and set pieces that it was a huge
inspiration for me on my time on this
project
our design Philosophy for creating new
and memorable enemies is basically
making them a combat puzzle similar to
like chess and focusing on the chess
pieces each piece has its own theme and
its own use you need to be able to see
what's happening in an instant and be
able to react as the player
there's a couple of different ways that
we go into making an attack very
readable for a player sometimes we add a
signature audio cue or we'll add the
different Rings such as what we did in
the last game that lets you know that
this attack is unblockable you need to
dodge it
there's so many different ways that the
effects really helps
not just show what an enemy is about to
do but show who the enemy really is
[Music]
to be surrounding the essence of the
character in a story it's what makes it
believable and memorable in the first
place
I'm excited about is for players to
experience the diversity of enemies that
this game has to offer
you will be fighting everything from
small little creatures to things that
will take up the entire screen
all their designs are on the gamut I
think each one looks so much different
from the next one and each of them have
their own play Styles and their own
little fantasies that go into it and so
I think if you are really into Norse
mythology you'll be very interested to
see how Sony Santa Monica has taken some
of these creatures and interpreted them
for God of War everything that goes into
the game there's emotion behind it and
intent behind it and by the time it gets
to you everything that you've seen that
you're going to play and experience has
been sweated over bled over tested and
is fun to play
PlayStation
[Music]